Let's do a homemade kitchen restock.
So I got started, actually,
really early in the morning on two loaves of sourdough bread
because my starter was ready and active.
Um, so I baked that later on.
And then I started by making my daughter these homemade popsicles.
These are super nourishing.
They have collagen, all the good stuff,
raw milk. Um,
and I just popped those in the freezer,
and they turn out really good.
Then I made us some gut healing,
like, gelatin gummies.
These are our favorite. I made mango flavor this time,
and they turned out so, so good that we went through them in, like,
two days because they were that good.
Um, so these are super,
super nourishing. And then I got started on, like,
these, like, sourdough, uh,
cheese crackers for my daughter.
I was gonna let these ferment,
but honestly, I just, like,
you know, I was like,
you know what? I'm just gonna bake them right away.
And I did. I typically don't do that,
but still, they turned out really good.
I'll just probably ferment them next time.
And then I made blueberry muffins for my daughter for, like,
early mornings for her to have, like,
a little, um, snack.
These have a lot of protein,
so I pop those in the oven,
and she absolutely love these.
And then the last thing is my, like,
homemade honey lemonade,
which I add a little splash of this to my herbal iced Tea every day.
Um, and just to have in the fridge.
We love this in the summer.
So I made that and that was all.